okay so let's play the c3 sicilian which
i've been advocating uh four players
of really all levels it's a great
opening and he immediately plays d6
allowing us to control the center
uh takes d4 which is not a great move
and the reason why
is because he allows our knight now to
access its natural square on c3 this is
the alpine situation
so nothing extraordinary we should just
continue developing
and if he goes bishop g4 we have a trick
that i've already illustrated in a
slightly different context it's happened
once or twice oh g6 i mean he's really
playing with fire here
taking his time to develop the pieces so
there's probably speaking two approaches
we can go for his throat
we can start pushing our pawns in the
center hoping that good things are gonna
happen
uh white is not winning by any means or
we could develop sort of old school
let's do the old school approach now
black now wants to develop the bishop to
g4
so what should we do about that this is
not a move that i play lightly because
it is kind of
spending a tempo but it's a very good
idea to restrict the development of his
bishop i see a lot of people just
playing h3 out of general considerations
but
you shouldn't do that you should only
play h3 um
if if there's a specific reason to end
it now bishop c4 here
would be a very typical mistake um
why is bishop c4 a mistake and where
should we put the bishop instead
who can tell me
we've seen this several times before not
knight a5 it runs into knight takes e4
and d5 i'll show that after the game
and so we can develop the bishop to d3
or to e2 i'm just going to go out to d3
in order to lend some reinforcements no
probably goes knight b4
not a problem we can just drop back to
e2 and look at this knight on before it
may look nice
but we can always just chase it away
with a3 so
it's not that i've lost the tempo it's
almost like we have both lost the tempo
um but i don't mind my bishop on staying
on e2 so
i guess the joke's on him now we don't
want we don't necessarily need to go a3
immediately that that knight is not
causing any damage to us i want to make
that point very clear i see a lot of
players
they look at a piece like this and just
because it's on our side of the board
they think it's dangerous well a knight
alone is not going to cause any trouble
because there's no targets on the queen
side right
we could have also played d5 to try to
remove the escape square from the knight
and threaten to win it with a3
but there's a reason i didn't do that um
and i'll show you guys why
after the game okay so he closes up the
center and goes 94.
what should we do here a key question
obviously should we take the knight yes
or no
and don't try to read my lips you know i
don't ask a question for the answer to
be something specific
we actually should now there's a
drawback to this mode which is very
clear which is that if you look
he now has a very nice outpost for his
knight but
here's the thing look at this pawn on e4
how is he going to defend it
he's not so he's losing a very important
central pawn
uh now you guys might be like wait a
second can't he defend it with bishop f5
or queen d5
he can but that's purely temporary both
of these moves
can be dealt with very straightforwardly
if bishop f5 we can go out to g4
chasing the bishop prying it away from
the ledge if queen d5
yep we could have gone bishop c4 and
done the very same thing to the queen
now
it is true that we have weakened our
king side and i've talked about the
situation right where
you have to make certain concessions at
this level uh in order to make other
gains
that's just part of the process and you
have to make the judgment call when it
is worth to do something like
weakening our king and here why have i
judged that it's okay because
uh two things first of all black has no
pieces really on the king's side
and second of all i've got all of this
beef over in the center so i'm really
not worried
um so what should i do now should i take
on e4
and there's some really cool tactics
that that that arise here
so we can play a3 but actually i can't
take on e4
and this is a very important moment
tactically speaking
hopefully he takes on a2 to allow me to
demonstrate
why i believe this is a good move um
let me just write this down
in case he doesn't so he trusts me
so after the game i'll be able to
explain that
okay so now we need to kind of figure
out what our priorities are
well first of all knight c2 i wouldn't
say that it's really a threat because
well because the bishop is protected in
fact we kind of want him to take our
bishop
so let's let's clarify the situation a
little bit let's bring our pieces out
onto better squares uh and let's force
him to just uh
you know decide what he wants to do so
that can be done with a move a3 i'm not
doing this to defend the pawn
i'm doing this to ask the knight a
question where is it going to go
um i don't want him hanging over me if
that makes sense right
if he goes knight c2 i'm just gonna go
rook c1 he takes my bishop no problem
i'll take back of the pawn now what
benefit
does white have from this trade why does
this trade actually benefit white i mean
doesn't it weaken my king even further
doesn't it ruin my pawn structure we've
talked about that first of all it opens
up the effo but
i want you guys to notice one more thing
it and that is the center we talked
about this
on several occasions right optically you
look at the pawn structure you say yeah
you know
three pawns in the center two of them
doubled not good
but if you look at it another way they
all defend each other it's like a big
conga line
and that's the best kind of center to
have okay
so that's why i'm always preaching about
not jumping to conclusions in regards to
pawn structure and what it looks like it
might look ugly
uh but it might contain you know a good
heart so let's see what he does i mean
his knight is hanging
he can okay so he takes he acquiesces
and the other good thing is that if rook
takes c1 queen takes c1
we couldn't have done this earlier
because this pawn would have been
hanging
but now the e3 pawn defends it so so
we're in very good shape okay
so he's gone bishop d5 uh he attacks our
knights we can we can move the knight
but we can also keep the knight in the
center which
is an idea that i like how can we keep
the knight in the center we need to
defend it
what do we defend it with we can defend
it by
bringing our bishop out to f3 deploying
it to a nice diagonal keeping the knight
centralized
and creating this bishop standoff now
remember
when we see a standoff we need to assess
immediately
the sort of weakness of this bishop this
bishop is a type two undefended piece
it's defended only by the queen
this queen could easily be removed so
i'm immediately looking for discovered
checks
such as knight f6 check in fact i need
to consider knight f6 here
and wait a second i'm connecting the
knots for a second
knight f6 immediately is possible but
that's not the best move
here's what we can do we can take on
passant
and now who can tell me what white can
do
rook takes ca queen takes it and now
just as the doctor ordered just as we
talked about
i takes f6 check we win a second pawn
and now we have a full center of black
has no pawns there
two extra puns and we're completely
winning in the end game rook takes f6
okay so i know that opposite colored
bishop end games have a reputation for
being quite drush
not entirely justified i mean if you're
up two connected passers
that doesn't you know i'm not worried
that there's obstacle bishops but what
should we do
how should we proceed here it's actually
not that easy i need to think for a
second myself
okay so boom
i'm calculating a variation
okay so what we need see i thought about
queen f3
uh but but it allows queen c1 check so
e4 is the very classic move but e4
weakens the d4 square
okay i don't really like that idea so
here's what i want to do i want to
contest the c file i want to contest the
c file
how should we do that well actually
what i'm going to do first is is move
the king out of the way okay i'm going
to go kg2
my idea is that now i can move my queen
out of the way
and if he gives me a ch and queen c1 is
no longer going to be a check so this is
actually not easy to
to figure out a way to plane but i'm
going to go queen f3 and here's the
whole idea
queen c1 is the move he would have
formerly had forking the king
and the pawn now he doesn't have it
now he can check me on c2 but i would
have easily covered that okay
let's freeze his pawns on the light
squares so that
later we'll be able to attack them with
a bishop
five gifted thank you so much tree poker
i really appreciate
it excuse me i really appreciate it
so what is our plan here our plan is
just to very methodically very carefully
push our past pawns particularly the e
pawn
and this is the whole idea the queens
are at a standoff the queen trade is
obviously just losing for black because
in addition to everything else we can go
after these pawns that's why we froze
them
now we go e4 and e5 very carefully
and what we can also do is okay so e5
here would blunder the bishop
how can we defend this bishop in an
active way
while also freezing his position
basically
queen f7 is what i was thinking actually
the problem is you can go back to c8
but then we can drop our bishop to b3
and cover the c2 square
okay now we can go e5
and we are simply winning we can let's
actually move our king in closer to the
center
now we switch roles right the king
defends the bishop
which means the queen is free to move
and it also means that we can go e6
and let's go bishop c6 and let's prepare
the queen trade on e8 first we can push
the pawn out
now we can go queen e8 and the game is
over because even though he succeeds in
blockading these pawns
now i go around and i take all of these
funds and be four pawns up in the end
not an easy game these guys are good
okay these guys are good and they resist
well
but i think positionally that was that
was a nice game
okay so let's quickly walk through
what happened now c3
sicilian right d6 is not the best move
although i've played it myself with
black you need to know what you're doing
here
and the move here is not f6 uh remember
can somebody remind me why is c takes d4
conceptually speaking not a great way
to play
ah dominique myers wait why are you not
vip
dominique myers needs to be vip
i'm gonna make him blush
okay gives white the big center but not
only that there's something very
specific guys
very specific look at this knight where
can this knight now go
okay the c3 that is a big development
square for the knight
if he keeps the pawns here at least this
knight can't develop to c3 while d2 is a
relatively clunky uh
clunky movement you got a choice well
then i might ban you
okay so by the way the cool trick if he
had gobbleshop g4 we can go d5
and if he goes 95 what
very common idea does white have who
knows this idea
it seems like we can't move the knight
because the queen is pinned
but remember the only pin in which you
actually can't move the pin piece is a
pin against the king
boom boom check knight d7 is forced to
avoid checkmate
and in the end of the day white is going
to be up a full
piece there's many openings where this
kind of stuff occurs
i would say most famously in the queen's
gambit
my brother played a game um years and
years ago he was 1500 and
he actually taught me this trick where
you go knight pd someone oh no i blunted
the pawn oh my god i can't take that oh
joke's on you and i takes d5 and
checkmate to the queen
because this is forced and black is up a
piece for a pawn poop male rock thank
you for gifting to bed woofer
uh so there's i can give you a million
examples of this
okay so he didn't do that h3 to stop
bishop g4 and aichi for
e3 bishop d3 just developing now if
bishop c4
knight takes e4 and d5 and
mark veretzky one of the most famous
chess coaches of all time unfortunately
passed away a couple years ago
and he was known for training very
strong players but he made a
recommendation
if you're very serious about chess
improvement i would actually
potentially recommend doing this i know
it's very clunky and
it's very time consuming if you can
start a notebook just like a real
physical notebook
uh or you can do it on the computer and
what you want to try to do is collect
tactical themes okay i know that sounds
weird let me explain tree poker thank
you for the dear yo
ten two one subs big boy donut right
there
tan tier one subs from tree poker thank
you so much
basically you collect tactical things so
every time you play a game
and either in analysis or in the game
itself you've noticed
some sort of cool tactical idea that you
think might be generalizable
such as this one or
such as this one you basically note it
down in your document
right or in your notebook and you can
describe it however you want
beretzky recommended actually printing
out for
even before printers literally drawing
on this notebook the diagrams or cutting
them out with scissors every time you
saw one in a book
and then you would revisit that notebook
and you would have
all you know in front of you a
very extensive list of tactical themes
that occur in your games
which you can learn and review thank you
shapes for the prime
okay uh what is a notebook a
notebook is is something that you write
and i still like handwriting
i hand write everything so i hand write
notes from the speed run
and that's it anyways back to the game
so this is all very simple okay
um
that comes later so takes takes knight
t2 right does this make sense guys now
the pawn is weak if he goes queen d5 we
would go bishop c4 get out of here
now what if he goes f5 what do we do
what do we do if he goes f5 oh i can
show it after the game yeah
what is writing
sorry for the chewing
trick question fork what do you check
when you fork two pieces
whether one piece cannot move and defend
the other piece
knife d5 defends against the check if
you go bishop c4 black and defend the
knight with e6
always check for that okay when you have
a fork unless it's a night fork in a
night in the situation of a night fork
the two pieces literally cannot defend
each other by definition
if you have a fork with anything but a
knife then if you think about the meth
one piece could slide over to try to
defend the other piece particularly a
fork where you check the king and
another piece can that other piece
move aside and block the check thank you
doctor lono for gifting
look at that 2am hive jpy gifting five
to the community thank you so much
this is ridiculous so you would take on
poisson and with the pawn
okay he played here we dislodged the
bishop take the knight
take the plum
force the knight to decide create a
massive pawn center
and what else was important in the game
and there we go as soon as we make this
move
stand off oh that might be in the
notebook as well bishop on d5 type 2
undefended peace defended only by the
queen can we dislodge the queen yes we
can
we can take his rook he should have
taken my rook to keep his queen
firmly in control of the bishop on d5
oh no not again
not again it's bobby boucher getting
five stops to the
throw community water on the fire what
did you start tree poke or another five
thank you poppy boucher so much um
well bishop d3 wouldn't create the
standoff right this would be like bishop
opposition
but curious chimpanzee gifting five subs
to the community
holy spokes oh my goodness what are we
doing ladies and gentlemen
why couldn't knight take oh yes thank
you for reminding me
why couldn't the knight take on a2 great
question
okay so let's unpack this for a second
right now just to remind you guys from
yesterday type 1 and type 2 on defended
pieces
a type 1 undefended piece and this is my
designation is a piece that is literally
not defended by any other pieces think
of the one crow for the 500
okay a type 2 undefended piece is a
piece that is defended by
exactly one other piece and my point
here is that type 2 undefended pieces
are a lot more vulnerable than people
realizing so the move here would be
queen to a4
we're trapping the knight the knight is
no way back and we're threatening to
capture it getting us
two pieces for the rook which is huge if
he goes b5
we can just slide the queen back to a3
and once again the threat of rook takes
a2 is completely unstoppable
he can try to call queen d5 but i mean
look at how many threats now we create
here this is just horrible for black
thank you good night okay now if he goes
bishop takes a2
then by the same token we can play the
very typical bishop b3 just trapping the
bishop
and then queen d2 to pick off either the
knight or bishop
well how did i notice that well i guess
my subconscious
indicates that when the knight is on the
on the rim like this
particularly when the knight is you
could also go in ic5 by the way but the
knight is
is you know so far away from black's
other pieces and it's on the rim
that sets off the metal detector right
because just mathematically speaking the
knight only has three potential squares
two of them are covered
one of them is uncovered so we need to
bring the square under control but we
need to do it in such a way
that we also reinforce you know ideally
the attack on the knight and that's why
queen a4 is played thank you mr luxies
keeps the hype going with a sub
appreciate it um knight on the rim is
dim that's right
okay so a3 chasing away the knight
well again be careful about the
generalizations and here we have a
discovery to win
the pawn now i think a lot of people
would uh
would go knight d6 here thinking ah i
can attack the queen and win the bishop
but
same exact principle the queen can move
away and simultaneously defend the
bishop you gotta be careful about that
okay so here we have a very simple
position
where where two pawns up both of them
are passed queen f3 here was the
tempting move
but he has queen c1 check super nasty
check for king
the pawn on b2 which i kind of hate so
that's why i play king g2 so that now
queen f3
doesn't allow the check on c1 it's a
preparative prophylaxis actually
and the rest is simple b4 fixing the
pawns on the same color
of our bishop now um
i actually disagree kind of with a piece
of advice that
chess coaches and books often share
about pawns and bishops let me turn the
lights on
all right made it dark but
it's a little too dark
now what exactly do i disagree with
i think that the prevailing wisdom is
that you're supposed to
or so the uh the sages right that you're
supposed to put
pawns not on the same color square as
your bishop
right and i actually think the efficient
sort of effectiveness of that is limited
because there's so many exceptions to
that rule
there's so many times when you do want
to put your pawns
on the same color of your bishop now the
way that i recommend to think about it
is oftentimes you want to make sure that
your opponent's pawns
are on the same color as your bishop
and you want to make sure that they're
fixed on those squares because
they're easier to attack so here for
example it doesn't really matter where
white's pawns are
it happens that they're on the dark
squares but that's not the important
part the important part is that black's
pawns
are on light squares fixed can't move
and so the bishop can easily attack them
it's low-hanging fruit
just a way to think about it you guys
can mull this over if it helps
okay queen f7 couldn't go e5 by the way
because of queen takes d5
check and now we bring our king into the
game
it's the end game e6 couldn't have gone
e6 before bishop c6
d5 queen eight trading the queens the
funny thing is
if not for these pawns it would be a
draw because white wouldn't have any way
to make progress
uh yeah i can play the karaoke okay
that's actually a very important point
it's only because of this idea that i'm
winning
i can show you guys a million examples
of opposite colored bishop and games
where i can even find probably a game of
mine where the pawns were arranged
exactly in this way or something similar
and there is no win because it's a
blockade paddle bro let me see what i
can find
give me a second please the danish is
interesting it's not very objectively
good but it's a very good
weapon for for beginners and
intermediate players
hard to play against in a blitz game let
me see what i can find guys give me a
moment please
thank you guys for all the subs and the
support as usual
yeah i found a good example okay so here
is okay let me just find it here and let
me show you guys a very instructive
example from one of my games i was able
to trick a very strong player
precisely along these lines and
this is to show you guys why opposite
colored bishop end games have a
reputation
as very draw asham games because in very
few end games
is it the case that you can give up two
or even three pawns
and still make an easy drop here you go
so
this is i think going to be really
interesting
so basically this is a game of mine
against julio grande very strong
peruvian grand master from 2015
and the following position was reached
i'm playing with the black pieces
um and clearly i'm in very big trouble
i'm down to pawn
and look at my king it's wide open but
what do you what else do you guys notice
about the position what jumps out at you
well i've got a pawn on on the f3 uh
square but what else what about the
bishops what do you notice about them
i wanted you guys to notice the fact
that there's obscure bishops which is
kind of interesting now white is winning
here
white is winning if he's careful uh
because because the
the you know the conjunction of black's
exposed king
with white's past pawns mean that white
is in very good shape now the rook on f2
is very safely blockading the f3 pawn
it's not going anywhere but my opponent
decided to play queen to d5
asking for a queen trait now i
immediately was thinking okay do i want
to trade queens or not
my first inclination was that if i trade
queens i allow him to have connected
past pawns which are super scary but
then i remembered wait a second
this is an opposite-colored bishop end
game so maybe i can set up some sort of
sudden blockade
and then i realized that i could and the
way that i do that
is by trading rooks rook g2 now he had
foreseen this he goes bishop to b6
defending the rook king b7 chasing away
his bishop and then
i go bishop e4 i basically forced this
pawn to move what is the idea
isn't this good for white it's not and
here's why
now look at the position i have full
control of these two squares
and that means that these pawns
intimidating as they may appear
are never actually going to go forward
and even though white can send his skin
forward
why can't he even win the f3 pawn which
he does he goes around and i just give
that pawn up
does it matter because i've got complete
blockade over these two pawns and this
pawn is on the light square
so i can always if need be defend it
with bishop c4 and here we go that's it
he can bring his king to f6 all he wants
doesn't matter
just chill with my bishop on the right
square okay so that's what you have to
be very careful about in opposite
colored bishop end games
a scenario where you can win several
puns but it ends up not mattering
because of the blockade here we have a
very similar position
but the threat of bishop b7 allows me to
vacuum up the rest of the bonds okay
next game
[Music]